like I want to have all these standards
for myself and these boundaries and I
want to be like my partner is going to
respect me and appreciate me and value
me and make me their equal and we're
going to be true partners and but then I
just allow little behaviors to undermine
that
and these are not little
behaviors yeah these are massive
fractures in a trusting loving
relationship period that's true but it
starts small it and then yeah it does
but these are massive
yeah you're right you're
massive and this is in a heteronormative
relationship this is in a gay
relationship this is in all
relationships you got to tell the truth